all right let's go to the phones for the
first time in the new year 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 we'll go to our caller from 7 8 6
hey 786 could you hear me talk about who
the new member was we're having a glitch
with our phone system we can't figure
out yes can you hear me yeah we can hear
you
excellent yeah I could hear about the
membership I'm considering joining no
there no that's hopefully in the future
all right what's on your mind who's this
by the way ok my name is Arthur from
Gainesville Florida I just wanted to
call you because ha I always ask you
about your comments on the armed
Venezuelan and other communist regimes
quote-unquote that you spoke of talking
about before I oh I thought it was
interesting that the way you described
it I remembered you described the
Venezuelan regime as a right-wing
authoritarian type of situation and I
just want to you can I maybe could you
expound a little bit on what you meant
by that because I mean I grew up in
Venezuela I'm actually a Venezuelan
myself
so I always find them interesting
because I mean Chavez did have a very
much very much eight and they focus on
all socialism as an ideology so they
like to reject the leftist armed
principles that inspired him to start
his government and with his
quote-unquote revolution I don't know
how I feel about calling him right away
so yeah it's not that so let me be clear
about that it's not that Hugo Chavez was
right-wing or that Nicolas Maduro is
right-wing there's no question that
their rhetoric and stated political
philosophy is that of socialistic
collectivist at minimum leftism no
question about it the implementation of
those individuals as as directors of
those regimes as presidents or whatever
as heads of state by their very
structure is we're very authoritarian
and right-leaning in the sense of total
government control control of the
judicial system lack of free press etc
etc so I think it's this is a really
good question because it's not that Hugo
Chavez's or Nicolas Maduro at least that
it's not what I'm saying
that their personal philosophy was a
conservative philosophy no their stated
philosophies were absolutely left-wing
populist communist socialist whatever
where do you want to apply to it they
ran inherently authoritarian and
right-leaning regimes in terms of their
implementation if that makes sense
sure yeah no it does I guess what I find
interesting is that when you hear the
typical American right winger they do
have a big focus on limited government
and no control if anything to keep
trying to blame the leftist we're trying
to be digital talent area was of course
I don't agree with that but right
there's always seems to be like what
they're throwing at you you know however
I mean I feel like it's ironic given the
way the Trump administration is handling
the executive branch and you know I mean
of course it goes back into it but I do
find it interesting because at least in
principle the right-wing ideology at
least by some in Ryan type is always you
know limited government less control and
that government or but just because
that's the other thing to keep in mind
Andres is that just because the right
claims that that's one of their
principles they're all about limited
government and hands-off assuming
everybody's doing what it is that they
want and as soon as they're not whether
it's abortion or gay marriage or what or
whatever else then all of a sudden it's
okay for the government to get really
involved
remember that double standard that
exists no of course I understand that
there's a hypocrisy when it comes to the
actions and prints of but I guess I'm
always trying to you know look at it as
what's on the text what what's on the
ideology itself because I can I mean you
can have a leftist as well being
hypocritical or what the way they run
the government
so absolutely always thinking when I
about the difference between you know
and the principle when you've written
down a way it's intended to be in the
way it's executed and well when I'm
doing I'm trying to differentiate
between the actions of right-wing which
is of course filled with hypocrisy and
what they supposedly want yeah have it I
guess that's where the label right-wing
kind of jumped out at me and I know that
you had a whole situation with them
sorry enough a cat who got who was I saw
your whole video on it that how he was
basically making fun of you criticizing
you for yeah trying to blame the right
for the left yeah yeah and of course I
mean that I my TV and radio audience
doesn't even know about that cuz I did
that just on YouTube since my broadcast
audience wouldn't know who Carl Benjamin
is but in any case yeah I had to defend
myself from things I didn't actually say
it was a whole mess but in any case yes
left-wingers putatively anyway who
implemented policy in a very
authoritarian right-wing way appreciate
the call
of course thank you thank you very much
appreciate it